[Music]  so everybody as tradition holds on every  film I don't you remember when this  started with my pictures but we started  doing toast before we shoot the first  shot and we always do atos just before  the last shot I have been dreading this  day for 59 shooting days I did not want  this to end I still do not want it to  end I have had the time of my life  literally as this is a time of my life  and I have felt completely embraced and  supported by all of you who knew what  this film meant to myself and to Tony we  sat down October 2nd 2020 and commenced  writing the script after a 80 90 page  treatment and then I called Christy up  and I said how soon can we make this  movie and Christy said what she always  says how soon do you want to make this  movie and I said well as soon as it's  safe and as soon as we can get an  enormous really appropriate cast and so  to the last shot lahaine  [Music]